قبل نحو 100 عام بدات تشكل النظام السياسي
للحكم في تركيا بتاسيس الجمهوريه التركيه
وتعيينهم مصطفى كمال اتاتورك رئيسا لها
واعطي رئيس البلاد سلطات مطلقه وكان عصمه
انونو اول رئيس وزراء للجمهوريه وتلهفت
صدق البرلمان في ابريل عام
1924 على الدستور الثاني الذي كرس حكم
الحزب الواحد لاكثر من عقدين ونصف حكما
خلالها حزب الشعب الجمهوري الذي اسسه
اتاتورك في نظام برلماني الى ان تاسس
الحزب الديمقراطي وحكم مرات متتاليه
تعاقبت على تركيا انقلابات عسكريه راهنت
مصيره ومستقبله نظامها السياسي بدءا من
انقلاب ما يعام 1960 على رئيس الوزراء
عدنان مندريس الذي تم اعدامه ثم ما عرف في
مارس ادار عام واحد وسبعين بانقلاب
المذكره وذلك في اشاره الى عسكريه للجيش
سقطت معه حكومه سليمان
فانقلاب سبتمبر ايلول عام 80 قده رئيس
هيئه اركان الجيش التركي الجنرال كنعان
ايفرين مع قاده الجيش الاربعه البري
البحري الجوي والدرك وذلك بدعوه حمايه
المبادئ الاساسيه للجمهوريه التركيه لينتج
لاحقا عام 82 دستورا جديدا هذا الدستور
عزز دور الجيش في الحياه المدنيه بدارعه
حمايه الجمهوريه والعلمانيه
حدث ما يمكن وصفه بالانقلاب الابيض بعدما
اصدر مجلس الامن القومي قررت اطاحت حكومه
النجم الدين اربكان وتم حل حزب الرفع لكن
منذ 2002 شكل فوز حزب العداله والتنميه في
الانتخابات التشريعيه نقطه تحول بارزه
بدات معها تحولات وتعديلات متدرجه في بنيه
النظام السياسي خصوصا مع فوزه المتكرر في
كل الانتخابات وقد شكلت محاوله الانقلاب
الفاشله في الخامس عشر من يوليو عام 2016
نقطه تحول بدورها دفعت عاما بعدها الى
استفتاء على تعديلات دستوريه شملت 18
تعديلا وتم اقراها
معالم هذه التعديلات الانتقال من النظام
البرلماني الى النظام الرئاسي بعد ان كانت
السلطه التنفيذيه ثنائيه البليه وتتكون من
رئيس الجمهوريه ومجلس الوزراء وتم رفع
ايضا عدد مقاعد البرلمان الى 600 هذه
التغييرات مهدت الطريقه لتنظيم انتخابات
تشريعيه كل خمس سنوات بدل اربع متزامنه مع
الانتخابات الرئاسيه باقتراع شعبي عام
والغي مركز رئيس الوزراء وتركزت ايضا
السلطه التنفيذيه في منصب الرئيس الذي كان
رمزيا ويتم اختيار الوزراء من قبله يعتبر
حزب العداله والتنميه واردوغان هذه
التعديلات جزءا من خطه للاصلاح الدستوري
والقانوني التي بداها الحزب منذ 2002 وذلك
لمجابهه تحديات امنيه وسياسيه ولكن ايضا
لتفادي الحكومات الائتلافيه الهشه ف
من القرن الماضي وحتى2 شكلت شكلت اكثر من
33 حكومه ولم يبقى اكثرها صمودا في السلطه
18 شهرا فقط وفي المقابل يرى معارض
اردوغان ان الانتقال الى النظام الرئاسي
خطوه تزيد الاستبداد تحت مسميات ديمقراطيه
ولهذا جاء اتفاق سته احزاب معارضه على
العوده للنظام البرلماني او ما سمته
النظام البرلمانيه المعزز في كل الاحوال
تعبر تركيا الجمهوريه نحو مئويه الثانيه
وذلك في ظل جدل واسع بشان نظام الحكم
وشكله